what i told my dad i was like dad you
need to just pick out my husband for me
i'm full of that now my dad won't do it
though he says he's good he's like i got
bit like he's like i'm busy i got other
things to do
okay would you get into an arranged
marriage
yeah if i thought he was like i have to
find the guy attractive because the
current method's not working is it
right so listen to this right so i i
propose a new method of relationship
right
so the new method is okay you don't
you get into a three-year contract with
your partner
okay three-year contract and within that
contract
everything
that you need and want in the
relationship is stipulated on by both
parties in that contract and after the
three years if you want to renew it you
renew it if you want to go
you go you know what that's probably not
a bad idea it's better than the current
situation what happened because the
current situation is not working
marriages are failing
the divorce rate is up sky high most
divorces are initiated by women so women
are clearly not happy right so i propose
and people laugh at me i'm like listen
if we have insurance
and rolling contracts for everything in
our life why not have it for
relationships
because then that takes away the
naturalness of a relationship the
naturalistic relationship is why the
divorce rate is so high and and why
women are initiated
i think that's just because people don't
know how to commit anymore to be honest
i think people struggle with true
commitment and knowing what it's like to
think it's the notion of i have fallen
out of love with you
[Music]
people don't realize that in
relationships sometimes they're going to
fall a little bit out of love you're
going to get tired of your partner
sometimes and then there's going to be
there's going to be times where you fall
back into love and you you feel the
spark again yeah you know don't fall in
love
don't fall in love
stand step into love thank you thank you
don't fall into it love's an action yeah
it's not a feeling
don't fall into love it's a it's not a
choice is it you no it might and that's
a problem yes you people tend to think
that
listen i'm a man you're a man yeah we
understand that when we we choose to
love who we're going to love it's not oh
my god i fell into it i don't know
what's going on i fell in love i don't
know
women do that yeah
women do that men actually choose who
they're going to have they listen i've
been in a place right where i've had
three women to choose from yeah
why are you laughing sorry she can laugh
this one i've had i've been in a place
where i've had three women to choose
from and i've chosen the one that i'm
gonna take
now all three of them just displayed all
the qualities that
were going to be for a
relationship but i said you know what
i'm gonna go there but we have that as
well we've got number one
but so it's so love is a choice but the
thing is but the thing is like but the
thing is like women i think okay i think
men do it too to be honest but women
like we choose bad boys yeah we do like
yeah we like we we're because we're
attractive who the hell we is y'all
struggling
like you told me
but you told me your ex was a serial
cheater like but that's like
like
no but that's what i'm saying like like
because but we don't go into the
relationship knowing that these people
are bad yeah you do i i think um
no because
i said from the start that i see [ __ ]
for what it is once i see that red flag
i know what the [ __ ] it is so you left
the first time you cheated
he cheated yeah the first time no
because i was young and stupid no but
that's what i'm saying i'm speaking for
me now
i'm not speaking
chess jessica the point is it's just
that you're like it's we're attracted to
bad traits at times that's the whole
point it's not saying you can't learn
and pick better in the future no it's
not yeah i think that's what sarah said
we just got to get all this vocabulary
of falling in love falling out of love
because that's just feelings okay i do
by our actions anyway three-year
relationships
nah you a lot you can you can do
relationships the thing that you all
don't seem to realize is that you guys
are significantly older than us three
years for us i feel like
is a long time like in our
the point i'm making is that it can be
tailor-made to whoever
is in the relationship you can say okay
let's do this for a year okay let's do
this for a year and a half you the two
of you can come together
make a contract because marriage is a
contract right make a contract that uh
benefits to both of you and within that
contract all the stipulations are there
whether you guys have children within
that time if you do what sounds like
marriage in the 1920s to me to be honest
and they were women stuck around even
though
i have a question for the panel do you
think that marriage worked before
because people didn't have the choice as
much to leave or because it actually
totally and plus they focused on their
duty not on their feelings
yeah
i thought you're going down a different
path that's why i just had to clarify
pearl says that sex is a duty in
marriage
i do i do think it's a duty i feel like
i feel like you're putting your husband
in a bad spot if you don't give him sex
because i think myself in a bad spot if
you're not giving yourself sex no that's
true i agree with you sex is the most
natural thing in the world yeah but
girls like girls will like not give it
to their husbands like that's a common
thing i hear guys complain about this a
lot do you think that maybe that's
insecurities within that individual that
they're not happy within themselves
they're therefore not happy with their
bodies and therefore don't want anyone
else touching them perhaps um
i think partially but i think sometimes
it's because girls feel like they
settled and they didn't actually want
the guy they married